hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión canadá en las américas café en
este caso la correspondiente al viernes
23 sábado 24 y domingo 25 de marzo del
2018 es la emisión que le proponemos
cada semana desde el sector en español
del servicio en español de radio canadá
internacional este reencuentro
hebdomadario sería semanal porque nos
advirtieron que se siguen franceses
tomate sería una traducción literal
literal y no corresponde en español
lo podemos hacer
semanal me parece más simple y más
práctico para quien dice nada le damos
la bienvenida a todos los que nos siguen
a través del facebook live y a quienes
optan por seguirnos a través del canal
de youtube donde tendrán todas nuestras
emisiones y por supuesto también pueden
recurrir a nuestro sitio en internet que
ustedes ya lo conocen el habitual www
ceín & punto sea así es que corresponde
barra y s de español ahí encontrarán
este programa y todos los contenidos que
producimos aquí en el servicio en
español hoy estamos aquí en el estudio
rufo valencia que está el grupo un
saludo como sabrá todos nuestros amigos
oyentes están por allá
con nosotros así que no no vacilen en
escribirnos si están si tiene alguna
cosa que decirnos algo como participar
efectivamente también está presente
pablo gómez barrios que está luis
laborda y un cordial saludo a todos los
que están allá del otro lado y como es
costumbre infaltablemente leonardo
gimeno que tal moros días buenos días a
todos buenos días a la gente que nos
está registrando desde el otro lado muy
bien exactamente mi nombre es luis
laborda les agradezco por estar aquí una
vez más y como siempre muchas gracias
por estar presente cada semana y
seguirnos a partir de las vías de
comunicación cada llamada
en esas vías de comunicación que van
creciendo semana a semana o tomada ha
tomado que darle un impulso al español
no sea es lo que hablamos dromader yo lo
he visto en la academia insisto en que
es complicado decir existe es un poco
engorroso si existe es es una palabra
más que hace para el español porque
francés español italiano y portugués
son todos cachorros de la misma loba sí
aunque no siempre aunque no siempre son
tan cercanos como la gente cree quienes
no conocemos esos otros idiomas creemos
a veces todos pensamos que podemos
hablar en italia y decimos que vino a
tomes
el famoso chiste de acreditarle de un
argentino que estaba en italia y que
decía estaba
somos o por favor puede traerme una
chiquita
tacita de café
viene de la argentina yo también y
porque hacemos hablando en italiano
justamente lo que uno dice que habla con
doble italiano que es la tonadita
italiana y termina cuando termine y
quiera saber cómo queda ese tono en el
porteño no hay muchas palabras en el
porteño que son tomadas del italiano hay
muchas palabras del lunfardo inclusive
que nosotros los que usamos
continuamente que han sido tomadas del
italiano
por ejemplo cada trabajo es elaboró
viene del lavoro italiano y nosotros
decimos laburo y el italiano y que lo
dicen los porteños también nervios de
lenguas hablando de un poco la
transmisión de hoy no necesariamente de
ese tipo de lengua sino de idiomas ok
un sentido no digo más
esta actividad periodística que nosotros
desarrollamos en este espacio de radio
canadá internacional se presta no
solamente a la información o al
esparcimiento que es otra de las
funciones que cumple la comunicación en
su más amplio sentido sino que nuestro
público la reformulada reconvierte la
reutiliza le da otro sentido otro valor
otra utilidad si uno quiere decirlo de
esa manera como es el caso por ejemplo
de una oyente france bernier que nos
envió un mensaje en el que dice hola
hice una inmersión en español en febrero
y estoy muy contenta porque ahora puedo
escuchar vuestro programa y comprendo el
idioma no soy camionera agua y cuando
venía caminando para el estudio me envió
una foto que tengo aquí en mi teléfono
móvil de ella en su camión
y quiero aprender español para hablar
con los latinos en los eeuu y canadá
me gusta mucho vuestro programa es muy
educativo divertido y los temas son muy
interesantes muchas gracias nos dice
entonces franz alguien que no solamente
parece ser que habla bastante bien el
español sino que lo escribe yo diría
casi perfecto por no decirle 11 sobre 10
así que muchísimas gracias a france y
ella es una de las que le encontraba
este espacio un nuevo significado de
decir toma este programa como se puede
hacer con muchos otros por supuesto y lo
utiliza para practicar su español que
tal pues fantástico es además que otra
cosa algo otro elemento a destacar es
justamente el tipo de trabajo que hace
ella que es de manejar un camión yendo
entonces me imagino que es un camión que
cruza fronteras porque estarán los
interés en hablar el español con los
conos que están con los 50 millones de
hispanohablantes al otro lado de la
frontera y además que es un oficio que
no es tradicional en las mujeres
me acuerdo por ejemplo como en méxico
había una serie de películas la trailera
que era justamente las historias de una
mujer que manejaba camiones en un mundo
y se les ha manejado en méxico los
caminos mexicanos son brutales porque es
una experiencia que no recomiendo pero
pues fantástico que podamos acompañarle
y mientras ella esté en la ruta que
digamos que esa es la idea
claro y es ese conducir el camión que es
además una tarea muy solitaria de unos
recorre tantas geografías y tantos
poblados y se encuentra con tanta gente
pero también tienen muchas horas de
estar frente al volante sólo a la
persona que conduce y en este caso
supongo yo aunque ella no lo dice
exactamente en su mensaje pero lo que
entendemos es que utiliza también ese
tiempo para escuchar nuestra misión y
nuestra misión y practicar su español
pablo no estaba pensando de que los
camioneros tienen muy mala fama en
colombia porque tú decías
gracias algo de alusión a eso y los
camioneros tienen mala fama por lo más
en el largo popular le dicen a los
camiones borradores porque te borran de
la ruta o sea hay muchos accidentes
provocados por los camiones y en general
cuando tú conduces un camión de estos
grandotes tractomulas él tiene un
accidente el que va llevando del bulto
es el que viene en un cochecito pequeño
no sí pero sabes que ese tipo de
situaciones que inclusive ha ocurrido
aquí ha ocurrido en el último invierno
con camiones que han arrollado a gente
en montreal y en otras zonas aquí de
quebec y de canadá a mí también me mueve
otra reflexión y es que muchas veces
quienes no ejercemos ese tipo de
actividades desconocemos de manera
desconocemos totalmente de manera
absoluta
el enorme esfuerzo y concentración que
requiere manejar uno de esos rodados si
por ejemplo quiera puede estar al frente
de un volante de uno de esos camiones y
guiar esas mesas molés esas bestias con
motor por las rutas que no siempre están
en perfecto estado y además cuidar de lo
que hagan nosotros es algo que supongo
yo bastante complicado al mismo tiempo
mi experiencia en las rutas argentinas
con los camiones es absolutamente
diferente a la percepción que no tiene
el camionero malo que tiene el cambio
encima siempre generoso siempre haciendo
señas siempre dejando pasar lo enfrente
avisando es otra relación yo le tengo
más
con cita a los taxistas
con una especie muy especial yo recuerdo
en mis épocas de trotamundos por decirlo
de alguna manera andando por las
distintas geografías argentinas y por
supuesto usaba de mis amigos los
camioneros para trasladarme un lugar al
otro y esta gente te lleva sin ningún
problema de una provincia a la otra con
el simple la simple condición por
ejemplo de que les seves más
ya me encontrado con gente que tenía no
solamente una formación sobre distintos
temas a nivel de cultura general por
ejemplo sino con por ejemplo siempre
recuerdo la anécdota de un camionero en
la patagonia que nos llevaba creo que de
chubut guau de río negro chubut y en un
momento detiene su camión y nos dice a
mi compañero y a mí que viajábamos los
dos con él bueno llegó la hora de comer
y nosotros claro teníamos unas benditas
insignificantes hay que compartir nos
daba casi vergüenza
las migajas que teníamos para compartir
con este señor ningún problema está todo
arreglado y de su caja saca una especie
de cofre y cuando lo abre tenía un trozo
enorme de carne salada quemada a la sal
hubiera sido menor o como se dice en
argentina tiene otro nombre no recuerdo
ahora parece que soy de buscar escapado
cocinada a la sal y además tenía todo un
una especie de gabinete de por decirlo
así no era exactamente eso pero de
vajilla agua para su almuerzo con el que
nos convidó nos sentamos todos comimos y
después de consultar gente su esponja la
voto perfectamente nos tomamos un
cafecito ordenó todo en su caja y
seguimos bien
sin hambre estaba bien equipado además
de que eso también nos muestra que los
rituales son necesarios si siempre
también decir por supuesto es bueno así
que nuevamente y saludos a nuestra amiga
también pablo en sí no regresando a
bernie cuál es su nombre franz bernie
que le encanta escuchar este programa
justamente para practicar su español me
hace pensar en el caso también de otra
oyente nuestra que a lo mejor nos está
escuchando en este momento guild en
abril allá en el cap l nuevo primer y
café leyes y entonces ella estuvo
aprendió su español en salamanca lo que
lo que dios nos dio salamanca de ella se
lo prestó porque no hablaba español y
fue justamente a españa para estudiarse
el español y al regreso de españa el
regreso de salamanca bueno quería
practicar y cayó por coincidencia en
nuestro programa y desde entonces no se
escucha muy asiduamente y bueno pues va
cumpliendo esa función la misma función
que cumple con el caso de france lo está
cumpliendo también en el caso de hitler
salvo que guillén es ya retirada
entonces ella está a la orilla del mar
en capel y tranquilo
[Música]
nuestro programa mientras le toca puede
manejar
vamos a escuchar la voz de guillén en
unos instantes en un separador pero si
ella está conectada no podrían ver un
mensaje con tantos granos si no están en
este momento en línea yo tengo aquí a
jugar con carlos miranda duarte y se
saludes de chile alguna vez pensaron
cuando la con la onda corta era el medio
preferido ahora están con los nuevos
medios si así es estamos y estamos
disfrutando los promedios juan as catón
dice hola saludos desde venezuela juan
carlos mirando a duarte nuevamente otro
mensaje se se ve muy bien por youtube y
se pueden promover para los seguidores
de youtube que existe una aplicación
llamada youtube go y que es para uso con
baja conexión a internet y se pueden
bajar vídeos para verlos sin conexión
pueden usar esto para ver el programa
sólo está disponible en algunos países
así que youtube go también es un consejo
de juan carlos miranda y javier nuestro
querido amigo javier gonzález nunca dice
luis leonardo pablo y rufo participante
del programa de hoy muchos saludos dice
la película se llamaba lola la trailera
dice
y leonardo de saltarme aventaste una
pedrada porque yo soy taxista que en
guadalajara
no está o no
guadalajara querido javier gonzález
lugar hay así que no puedo hablar de los
taxistas allí aquí son una especie muy
especial porque de manera muy bien
saludos entonces javier y cuando alguno
de nosotros anda de visita por allí que
se acuerda de que somos amigos que no
hay comentarios intencionados
pues se pueden comer una alguna delicia
mexicana que está pasando a otra
cuestión a otros asuntos cuáles son los
temas digamos extraños' poco
convencionales inéditos locos que nos
han llamado la atención en estos últimos
días a mí me llamó la atención está esta
conexión en interespecies que se produjo
en un lugar en canadá no recuerdo
exactamente el nombre pero tienen nombre
fantástico también una pequeña localidad
de el corazón el con el buen coral del
pueblito lleva buen corazón
nombre de ese género en el cual un grupo
de delfines quedó atrapado en la bahía y
se formó el hielo detrás de ellos y era
muerte segura para ellos porque estamos
todavía en invierno el hielo bomba va
justamente acumulándose y los delfines y
va además avanzando y los delfines
tenían cada vez menos y menos espacio la
historia es que básicamente todo el
pueblo todo el pueblo decidió ver qué
hacer entonces había gente que iba en
botecitos golpeando el hielo tratando de
abrir pero pues inútil no porque el
invierno es no
es demasiado intenso lo que hicieron fue
que pues gente que tenía empresas
locales traje mares enormes para las
mecánicas y se fueron a los dos costados
de la bahía y empezaron a jalar a
retirar ya quebrar el hielo y finalmente
otros botes más fueron para empujar los
grandes bloques de hielo y finalmente
finalmente después de uno dos o tres
días pudieron abrir una vía para que los
delfines puedan salir
una vez el dt sabía entonces los
delfines pues no posaron no pero no se
los veía se veía el dorso clásico de los
delfines ya yendo a mar abierto y la
gente muy emocionada la gente lágrimas
no es decir finalmente era era era eros
fue un elemento un momento en que toda
la comida vino se puso a trabajar juntas
y logró eso que estos delfines salgan
salgan a lala la tama
y no pierdan la vida en dos sobreviven
el crudo invierno entonces y eso fue
además lo que me gustó fue que esa fue
la última noticia en el boletín de
principal boletín de noticias de la
radio pública en inglés y esto en un
contexto en que puedes primeras
entidades son ese circo de catástrofes y
monstruos en washington las guerras por
aquí
el caso de yemen y arabia saudita o sea
que por todas partes veis explosiones y
bueno aquí un grupo de gente trabaja se
pone a cuatro tipo de explosión es una
situación de lágrimas
digamos que algo más decente más humano
entonces me llama atención perfecto muy
bien pablo alguna noticia
y una noticia que me llamó la atención
fue la semana pasada creo y alomejor
leonardo tú ya estás enterado fue de
este primer accidente mortal de un auto
aún un carro autónomo sí sí que sucedió
en arizona en estados unidos en el que
era un y berja un carro y ver y
über exacto entonces si lo pronunciamos
a francés todo entonces hubo este
accidente en el que el carro atropelló a
una mujer y no se explica todavía qué
fue lo que sucedió pero ha tirado como
un manto digamos así de sospecha sobre
la tecnología como tal o sea este es
cierto qué
se pregunta a la gente si se puede
confiar verdaderamente en los carros
autónomos en el que a pesar de que había
en el auto había un chófer designado
porque creo que ese es el principio no
que hay un chofer designado que en caso
de algún problema tiene que tomar el
control
ni siquiera el chofer pudo tomar control
es por qué
se conocieron imágenes y el chófer es
sorprendido casi ve a la persona cuando
el auto ya está rozando si entonces la
pregunta es si era que el chofer estaba
distraído porque estaba justamente con
su teléfono me dieron la otra versión
era que estaba muy muy concentrado en
los instrumentos del vehículo y
finalmente bueno la realidad es que la
mujer murió y que la ex presidente se
produjo entonces y que hay cierta duda
en cuanto a la seguridad no de tener
imagínate este solo uno cuando haya un
montón de carros autónomos en las
carreteras pues cuál es la seguridad que
existe y está la vieja discusión que ya
hemos referido aquí en algún momento de
que ahora que ocurrió este accidente y
quién es el culpable y quién se hace
cargo del mismo a quién se pena al dueño
de automóvil a quién debía estar
conduciendo luego a quien luego puso en
servicio a la empresa a la que
corresponde esa es una discusión
y estamos en la misma vía de a quien
condenamos a zuckerberg al amigo que
hizo la aplicación
por la que facebook facebook que ahora
está en
con un ojo bien exacto entonces en ese
tipo de cosas donde la tecnología está
presentan presente es bastante complejo
y el tema de ese tipo de accidentes yo
he ido manejando y he visto como alguien
abordaba una persona y cuando la persona
está decidida tras hacer frente a un
carro no le hace señas al carro y aunque
sea muy inteligente el carro ay exacto
fracciones de segundo y no hay
posibilidad de frenada anjé o sea es
complejo tanto desde la infraestructura
de lo inteligente como de la estructura
del cerebro de la persona que quiere
hacerse daño digamos en este caso no sé
si esta persona quería hacerse daño no
lo leo en genk y sevilla de una mujer
que va cruzando no yo no sé si la verdad
al orgullo porque aparentemente era de
noche y estaba todo muy oscuro y ella
iba cruzando con su bicicleta a pie y
iba ti y llevaba su bicicleta al lado y
la imagen que se ve cuando el auto está
encima de esta persona no no se la ve en
ningún momento
12s al contrario tratando de terminar de
cruzar y no llega a hacerlo también tal
vez por el hecho de que haya sido de
noche los sistemas de detección no
funcionaron como se esperaba bueno hay
errores en los sistemas de detección y
ese fue el primer accidente de tesla
también donde falleció una persona con
en realidad la propietaria del auto que
fue en una en una vía en una ruta de
doble sentido con un bulevar en el medio
un camión que dio vuelta el camión
arrojó el acoplado era blanco el sol
estaba ruido del camión
el auto no lo distingue al cuarto pero
la persona venía a 185 kilómetros por
bueno o sea por eso digo hay cuestiones
que hay que rever y por supuesto esto no
está aceptado primero
están haciendo test así que supongo que
todo este tipo de cosas y yo en el caso
de que todos los autos estén va a ser
menos complicado todavía porque
precisamente conectados y claro aparte
de que quieras comentar la atención
sigue llamando de atención a la crónica
le dice sobre eso la historia de
facebook y de esta locura por irse de
facebook ahora por qué porque no se
investigan entonces mandamos de
cualquier país del mundo porque no se
investigan o sea no es nuevo que se
investiga este programa mismo es para
nuestros amigos
yo tengo una historia extraña una
noticia información extraña que comentar
y s
primero quería que quería partir con una
pregunta que es para ustedes una colina
una colina si es una montañita pequeña
para mi juicio pequeña qué quiere decir
bueno con un desnivel de unos 100 metros
están los oteros que son pequeños
pequeños montículos de las lomas y está
mogollón aquí en la ciudad de montreal
que tendríamos una nueva montaña es un
hombre grande sería un poco por montaña
sí que me dirían ustedes si les dijese
que en china ya en el condado de john
wang en el que wang en el este del país
e identificaron lo que se llama la
colina de yinka que es una formación
rocosa de 60 centímetros de alto
por 70 de ancho y un metro y medio de
largo porque durante mucho tiempo eso se
conoció una piedra que considera
cualquiera y una foto ahí en el artículo
que yo fotocopie que muestra lo que
parece ser una piedra y nada más que yo
entonces no dice pero por qué demonios
esto es considerado una colina uno llega
una colina y se encuentra en una recta
de 60 centímetros de alto y piedras
mucho más grandes que se colina en todo
caso bueno hubo quienes quisieron
moverla y al intentar moverla como en la
leyenda de excalibur se encontraron con
que esta piedra se extendía hacia lo
profundo y que hacia lo profundo tiene
una extensión mucho más grande de lo que
se puede ver
en una isla en superficie una especie de
albert pero en la tierra
y que entonces por más que parezca una
piedrita insignificante perdida lo es en
el este de china es efectivamente y así
lo han dicho los científicos por lo
menos una colista se midió más o menos
que altura que es en cuanto tiene en
total con lo que no por lo menos este
artículo que es muy breve no lo miedo
reseña pero efectivamente hay una colina
debajo de esta piedrita de 60
centímetros que veíamos ahí porque la
china actual también se ha dado a
inventarse islas realistas artificiales
entonces quizás está en el espíritu de
la época hacer de presenta dentro de su
propio territorio así que no creo que
pudiese reivindicar nada a partir de
esta colina no se entiende la colina más
pequeña del mundo bueno
me hace pensar que creo que es una
película que se llama el hombre que
subió una colina y bajo una montaña no
sé si le dice a alguno a ustedes eso el
hombre que soy una colina o una montaña
era que entre la diferencia justamente o
sea porque el tema se presta de cuál es
la diferencia entre una colina y una
montaña
entonces no hay gráfico el tipo quería
que esa colina se convirtiera en montaña
aunque entonces empezó pero le faltaba
para hacer una montaña le faltaba
más o menos un metro si entonces lo que
él hizo fue que comenzó en él cuando
estaba arriba de la colina comenzó a
amontonar piedras y allí para completar
el metro le faltaba eso atrás entonces
por eso fue que subió una colina y
finalmente bajo una montaña muy curiosa
no está bueno entonces vamos a escuchar
a nuestra oyente
chrysler que nos envía saludos y que nos
recomienda escuchar nuestra emisión si
nos mira nuestra técnica a ella le
decimos
estoy en 3 de capel y en nuevo brunswick
una provincia de cadera y los invito a
escuchar canadá en las américas casi el
programa dominical de radio canadá
internacional en la web
pero puede hablar perfectamente español
con la gente que se encuentra en el
camino por supuesto que utilizan esta
emisión para practicar su berni
nuestra gente jubilada que está hay
30.000 esperando el momento en que dicen
ya viene hervidos esos esos
eso me llamó la atención que empezó la
primavera
de hecho este es el primer programa de
la primavera aunque mucho no se ha
notado hasta ahora la primavera tenemos
amigos afganos en español o iraníes
también el año nuevo el nawruz sí señor
un saludo a gente de áfrica sí claro
allí estaba y trabajaba universidad que
memoria rufo porque escribía escribiendo
muy buena gente labios 3 mozambique y
también cita y había otro y uruguay el
gol hablo angola y la cola puede que
hagamos una transmisión casco azul lo
que es nuestra primavera a ver podemos
conectar el skype y ponerlo en la
pantalla y yo salgo con mi teléfono de
contacto con ustedes perfecto y hacemos
una vuelta al cuero mientras tanto
podemos ir leyendo algunos mensajes de
los que nos hacen llegar nuestros
oyentes a partir de nuestro sitio en
internet
rufo si entonces es un mensaje sobre el
tema más crece lópez obrador en sondeos
más con del pánico en washington
jose agustin dice muy de acuerdo con
este artículo así como los mexicanos
queremos vivir en paz democracia y en
una buena relación con el mundo dice
jose agustin sobre el mismo tema termina
hay otro hay otro mensaje por acá que de
mario rendón picos dice vamos a depurar
completamente los tres poderes ejecutivo
legislativo y judicial así que esa es la
propuesta de mayor
rendón picos si daniel roselló quien nos
envía un mensaje él dice saludos a todo
el colectivo de radio canadá
internacional me llamo daniel y les
escribo desde cuba me gustaría saber más
de la emisora y de su programación
saludos
danielle entonces tenemos ese mensaje
otro por acá que nos envía
no sé su nombre no está escrito
información de trabajo dice según
aparece en facebook que radio canadá
internacional publican necesidades de
personas para diferentes trabajos
quisiera saber si es verdad y el en
verlo un saludo cordial y yo creo que
aquí hay una confusión hay una confusión
porque los mensajes que aparecen ahí fue
un reportaje que se hizo con respecto a
las diferentes profesiones requeridas
aquí en canadá y bueno mucha gente nos
envía mensajes a nosotros para decirnos
ayúdenme yo quiero ir a canadá yo hago
esto yo hago esto otro y hago esto otro
entonces pero no somos nosotros vidente
mente de radio canadá internacional los
que ofrecen el trabajo y lo que estamos
haciendo la promoción nosotros
publicamos un restaurant ag en un
momento dado que ha sido muy popular y
al que la gente pues hace alusión y en
particular la persona que nos envió este
mensaje bueno obligado eso yo tengo un
mensaje que nos envían camila
sobre el tema canadá ofrecerá una
entrada rápida inmigrantes cualificados
en 50 ocupaciones a partir del 1 de
enero de 2015 y se quisiera viajar para
estudiar y terminar mis estudios
prepararme un poco más para así poder
ejercer me como persona y ayudar a mi
familia entonces le decimos la misma
camina en los sitios en internet de
inmigración canadá pueden encontrar toda
la información correspondiente lo que
tiene que ver no solamente con el
proceso de inmigración sino también lo
que hace a la posibilidad de encontrar
trabajo y de erradicarse definitiva o
temporalmente en este país pablo paiva
leonardo aiba leonardo y en este momento
se está dirigiendo hacia la salida lo
que vimos al principio es el pasillo de
radio canadá en la casa acá y ahora esa
es la salida como pueden ver ahí se
enamoró fue un abrigo protector que se
pone todos los inviernos para que la
gente cuando llega aquí ya no llegue
y ahí nos está mostrando la primavera en
montreal
en las afueras de la radio canadá
internacional es decir de primavera
hasta ahora poco y nada ustedes son muy
exigentes y apenas está comenzando
comenzó anteayer cómo quieren que la
nieve desaparezca the world
se está haciendo más calor hay menos
nieve que la iniciadora la semana pasada
y hay que tomar en cuenta que el monte
este invierno a cada instrumento estamos
en pleno calor de miami en comparación a
nunavut por ejemplo en el jardín donde
hemos estado y hemos podido ver el rigor
del gran norte canadiense de leonardo
cuáles son tus impresiones las
impresiones son digitales no frescas
digo está frío y así como estaba dentro
de estudio hace un momento nada más así
que
les podemos mostrar aquí este es el
edificio la torre de radio canadá
muestra donde se está construyendo el
nuevo edificio leo a tu izquierda a la
10 se está construyendo el nuevo
edificio ahí va a hacer de la grúa ahí
se ven las grúas y la construcción no se
va a dar mucho ahí se ve un poco de la
estructura del edificio que va a ser
nuestra casa a partir del año 2025 no te
equivocas es el 2020 en efecto si no
está bien
ahí estamos caminando hacia allá bueno
interesante la experiencia y ahí está la
primavera y muy soleado no es tan cierto
o por lo menos podría decir que se
escuchan un par de pajarillos así que la
pregunta es el sangrado hacia dónde está
él aunque no lo veamos decía la canción
el sol siempre está está atrás de la
torre y atrás de las nubes pero bueno
suponemos que en algún momento
saldrá ahí está la nueva discusión del
edificio si es la obra
bueno eso es entonces una visión de lo
que es el comienzo como decía pablo de
la primavera aquí en montreal hay otras
regiones de canadá que están como
señalaba rufo con temperaturas mucho más
bajas y sobre mantos de nieve mucho más
importante que éstos pero también hay
otras zonas que están con temperaturas
más altas
donde crece el plátano y es un clima
formidables no hay pues un decir es la
región más cálida en todo en todo canadá
una región de los hoyos es muy apreciada
por los jubilados donde crece en plata
nosotros llegamos de forma a ornamental
lo hay
si crece en planta nos fundamental es
bueno vamos a ir a un pequeño separador
y luego vuelvo con los temas que hemos
estado trabajando durante esta semana
llena de ángeles habla marco castillo
productor músico brasileño que vive en
winnipeg y los invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas café
de la radio canadá internacional en la
web exacto y decías pablo que viene
leonardo caminando nuevamente para aquí
y entrando al edificio principal de la
radio canadá internacional ahí ven
ustedes el especie de carpa protectora
que hace que la gente no llegue en valor
nada de nieve hasta la puerta misma tú
tienes una sí no
tiene que estar peleando a las cinco y
media de la mañana que nuestra
experiencia más agrado pero entonces
gracias a él skype y él nuestro
compañero leonardo gimeno una visión de
lo que es el comienzo de la primavera
aquí en montreal
queridos colegas cuáles son los temas
que usted es de los que ustedes han
estado trabajando esta semana que les
sugieren a nuestros oyentes con
particular atención lo que está con esta
semana para esta semana fue justamente
acceso a los documentos firmados por el
ex gobierno conservador de canadá
stephen harper
quien en 2014 firmó un convenio de venta
de equipos militares
a arabia saudita ahora una de las
condiciones de ese de esa venta que no
es poco dinero son 15.000 millones de
dólares es que los términos de ese
contrato permanezcan secretos tanto para
canadienses o como sea para todo el
mundo y según los términos de ese
acuerdo el hecho de que se dé a conocer
este documento sería una una ruptura una
ruptura del propio acuerdo entonces lo
que resalta de esta de accesos
documentos es que no se vendió lo que
supuestamente se vendía según tanto en
vista del primero y sohar porque decía
que se estaban vendiendo camiones
y el propio primer ministro liberal ha
sentido que aunque presentó plataformas
muy opuestas a lo que era el gobierno
conservador una de las coincidencias es
que el gobierno liberal decide que va a
continuar y que va a respetar ese
convenio y que lo que están vendiendo
son son chips pero en realidad son el
último modelo de carros blindados el lap
6 que justamente pues fue objeto de
mucha controversia y mucha resistencia y
mucha crítica de parte de organismos
preocupados por los derechos humanos
porque arabia saudita está enfrascada en
este momento una guerra contra una una
facción en yemen una una guerra que está
costando que tanto unicef como naciones
unidas han han denunciado los
devastadores efectos de esta guerra eeuu
proporciona por ejemplo a la aviación de
arabia saudita combustible en vuelo sin
saber para qué sirven y qué objetivos
están siendo afectados entonces es en
ese contexto que finalmente pese a las
intenciones tanto del gobierno
conservador como el gobierno
y sale a la luz pública estos estos
documentos y otra otra sorpresa es que
además no es solamente venderlos los
equipos militares estos blindados
que supuestamente eran chips y camiones
y no tienen la asistencia técnica por 14
años que implica la implantación de
grupos de trabajo de canadienses en
general ese territorio en tres en tres
partes en arabia saudita
entonces organismos como clusters y
otros organismos de la sociedad civil
canadiense pues han denunciado este este
acuerdo han pedido al gobierno liberal
de que se anule ese contrato por
justamente porque va contra los
principios de las ventas militares
canadienses la respuesta del gobierno
federal es que van a modificar las leyes
cristian fue la en la ministra de
relaciones exteriores dijo que bueno de
ahora en adelante vamos a tratar de que
no ocurran estas cosas pero estamos en
un contexto de guerra no declarada que
en arabia saudita así que ese es la
dígame lo que destacó está este comercio
de las armas que está pues alimentando
desde la guerra civil básicamente el
conflicto en méxico entre narcos y como
las guerras que son la que es el mejor
negocio bueno está el sitio
en nuestro sitio internet así que todo
lo que le interesa el tema la pueden
consultar nos empieza a correr el tiempo
para lo cuál es tu tesis y muy
brevemente louis mi tema es mucho más
ligero que el de robots y es sobre todo
una entrevista que hice con una
bailarina mexicana que está presentando
su espectáculo que se llama estudios y
fragmentos sobre el sueño que está
presentando este espectáculo en el marco
del décimo festival de danza del
festival internacional de danza de
vancouver entonces que comienza
justamente su espectáculo lo presenta
hoy y mañana y bueno empecé en donde
ella nos habla de él de su arte que no
es una danza convencional sino una danza
experimental en la que siempre se está a
la búsqueda de nuevos movimientos de
nuevos movimientos en el cual ella
integra
esta danza japonesa cuyo nombre se me
escapa en este momento y bueno el kabuki
no no es kabuki ese puro no recuerdo
últimamente en fin es cuando ella
estudió ballet clásico y comenzó un poco
tarde
en la danza pero después se dio cuenta
que lo suyo no era el ballet clásico y
que lo que ella quería hacer era otra
cosa es manifestarse expresar su cuerpo
su arte de otra forma en fin es
interesante y bueno pues los invito a
escuchar la entrevista con ella en rcn
punto seas perfectos ya también está
publicado allí y un árbol esto va a
salir mañana pero en realidad tiene que
ver con lo que viene pasando atento esta
semana con la historia de facebook las
elecciones eeuu la venta de esta base de
datos con 50 millones aproximadamente de
perfiles y de perfiles con realmente en
la definición de perfiles o sea no
solamente la información básica sino un
estudio con respecto a cada una de esas
personas
cotejando información
bueno la participación en red social y
en otros elementos que componen el
perfil de la persona esto vendido a una
empresa que se llama cambridge analítica
que lo que hicieron según lo que se supo
fue
como están segmentados el estudio
lograron dirigir publicidad específica
para cambiar la intención de votos de
gente en estados unidos particularmente
para la elección de una versión de
trance y se supo después que han
participado en realidad en otras en
otros países incluyendo países de
américa latina y algunos de europa con
respecto a la salida del break si desde
gran bretaña también o sea realmente el
espionaje al detalle y dejándonos a los
usuarios de las redes sociales como el
producto a vender no nosotros compramos
un producto si nosotros somos el
producto perfecto entonces a partir de
mañana sábado la nota estará en nuestro
sitio internet por mi parte les sugiero
o los convidó con una entrevista que le
hice a valerie a vergara dice es una
científica investigadora de lobos en
wise con profesión sitios en vancouver y
rufo hablaba de los delfines en este
caso
valeri a hablar de las belugas que
algunos grupos de verrugas están en
peligro de extinción entre ellos un
grupo muy importante que existe en el
golfo
y el río san lorenzo que está muy
cerquita de aquí y ella nos habla por
supuesto de entre las razones que
podrían favorecer la extinción de esta
especie y el cambio climático por un
lado pero por sobre todo la
contaminación sonora las belugas están
catalogadas como animales cetáceos muy
sociables y se los denomina canarios de
mar por la cantidad de sonidos que
emiten esos sonidos los utilizan para
comunicarse entre ellos y para poder
orientarse en la búsqueda de alimento
entonces la interferencia sonora hace
que esa comunicación falle y le
agregaría un peligro más a la
supervivencia de esta especie el tema ya
está divulgado en nuestro sitio de
internet no tenemos mucho más tiempo y
no solamente decir que esta semana y que
hagamos un minuto de silencio después
que aunque sea que termine la emisión
por el último rinoceronte blanco que fue
que pereció esta semana entonces ya no
hay solamente blancos en modo natural se
nos terminó el tiempo se murió se murió
el programa también así que verón es
referencia a renacer como el ave fénix o
félix
bueno muchas gracias a todos por estar
aquí como en cada semana salud a los que
nos siguen por por facebook por youtube
en nuestro sitio en internet y como
estamos en la semana del idioma francés
y la francofonía nos vamos a ir con un
tema en francés que se llama el déficit
de móvil y legitiman es así las chicas
de montreal de no recuerdo ahora quién
no recuerdo de quién es el intérprete de
este tema pero que habla de las mujeres
de esta ciudad que es una ciudad
eminentemente francófona y que no son
forzosamente igual en invierno y en
verano ya verás lenta al menos muchas
gracias a todos y nos reencontramos en
la próxima emisión en la próxima semana
chau hasta la próxima adiós o
pero
[Música]